[Music]
anthony
is with us in san diego to start off
this hour hi anthony how are you
dave how's it going thanks for having me
on your show our pleasure sir how can we
help
uh so i've got a lot going on right now
for sure
i feel like i'm ready to live in a box
and get out of debt because it's so
stressed
so much stress and anxiety all the time
from for me
and my wife is like
she's on like she's learning and doing
some of the steps
but she's just like not as intense as i
am and uh
it's hard for her for me to expect that
from her with
you know our lifestyles that we've grown
up with and uh
so it's so i just said not sure how to
how to get her on the same page as me
and uh we're like in the middle of
selling our house right now
you know to pay off debt and buying a
new place
and so there's just a lot going on yeah
confused as to what your question is
give me an example of what's going on
where you're struggling
sounds like you're on the same page
you're selling the house right
yeah so where is it you're not on the
same page i mean
like i could well i have you know i have
i have a kid he's a year old um
somewhere right on the same page as like
selling the truck and a fifth wheel that
we have
we have it's we have a loan for 60 000
i mean i wish i knew about big ramsey
like a year ago before i made all these
financial decisions
uh but uh basically we bought a truck
and we bought a fifth wheel
um fifth wheel's at forty thousand
dollars
and then the trucks are on sixty
thousand dollars for loans
so a hundred thousand dollars on these
two items and you wanna sell them and
she doesn't
yeah okay why does she not wanna sell
them she thinks you're going to pay them
off quickly
yeah she thinks that we can it's like so
because for we're selling our house so
the only smart thing
i've ever done with my money is that
when i got here
in san diego i bought a house right away
uh back in 2016.
so how much are you gonna make on the
house when you sell it
uh i'm gonna walk away with like 165k
okay but you're gonna go buy a cheaper
house
um i don't i mean
probably not oh you're gonna go rent
okay how much debt do you have
uh so i have the hundred thousand
dollars in loans
i have 73k on credit card debt and
what's your household income
um so i'm i'm in the military i make
like 100k a year
um and then we rent out a room uh
so is your wife work outside the home
uh no not right now but she wants to
pick up the job she'll probably
be making a couple thousand dollars a
month now how old are you guys 25
26. okay how did your wife
she's 27. okay okay
here's just some common sense okay for
both of you yeah
and it's not a matter of intensity and
it's not a matter of who's right or
who's wrong
when you own stuff with wheels and
motors
that totals more than half your annual
income and it goes down in value very
very quickly it is
very difficult to win financially
yeah and so you have a bunch of crap you
can't afford
even if you paid it off yeah i mean
it's just hard to convince her because
you know i get a
steady income and like yeah but your
steady income is not enough to justify a
hundred thousand dollars worth of pickup
and fifth wheel when you only make a
hundred thousand dollars
you're gonna lose twenty thousand
dollars a year on this little get up
while you're making a hundred it's going
the wrong way at a faster pace than it
needs to with your income
if you made 400 000 a year you could
justify this
if you paid it off quickly but you're
you know so i would not take the house
money and pay all of this off i'd take
the house money and pay off the credit
cards and i'd sell these two dad gum
things
and buy you a car with a house money or
a truck with a house money that you pay
cash for
and the total of all your vehicles with
wheels and motors needs to be less than
50
000. if you want to win with money now
if you want to go around and be stupid
and normal
stupid and normal's everywhere that's
not that's a long line to get in
yeah i mean i understand that it's just
been tough for me to relay that
uh well it's a simple math thing it's
not an emotional thing
it's not a your right she's wrong thing
it's a honey
when we bought this we were stupid
we didn't have the money to do this when
you make a hundred thousand dollars and
you own a hundred thousand dollars worth
of crap that's going down in value
it's hard to get ahead
we need to undo our stupid here
this is the conversation we have at our
house yeah i was just about to say that
because i heard anthony laugh and he was
like dave you're asking me to go to my
wife and say
we were stupid i i think this
millennials he was stupid yeah i don't
care but there's lots
there's plenty of stupid to go around
here anthony's like i'm going to be
sleeping on the couch dad
well i mean we want to keep the dadgum
trailer
that's right so we is stupid you know we
can figure this out here but um you know
so
but you can you cannot be insulting if
you don't want to be that's fine the
point is
that there's a simple math thing going
on here this is not a
i think we can afford it because we can
pay the payments thing that's what
children say
you know i'm not married okay but this
is what i was saying
i i definitely don't don't don't go to
your 27 year old and say we were stupid
i would go to her and say hey babe
here's a vision that i have for the
family that i think we're both aligned
with we want to be financially free we
want to be debt free we want a
prosperous life
and right now these two decisions that
we made
that's preventing us from getting there
quicker i know you don't like this but
can you just trust me
i talked with dave i got some wisdom
they all agree that we need to sell
this and eventually one day we can get
back there but if we could do this
sell this sell the house we could be
financially
free within the next three to six months
and i think that's a good way of saying
we're stupid without saying we were
stupid
now we're saying we're smart you're just
you're just so much smoother than i am
but the uh
um so here's the thing guy the other
thing i heard you say
that's the problem here you said i'm
stressed out
yeah well that tells me that she hasn't
got a clue what's going on with the
money and she's not carrying emotionally
any of the weight of your all's bad
decisions
she's acting like you're her daddy not
her husband
and when she feels the weight of this go
across her shoulders
which she needs to feel because she's
like a grown-up and everything
then she's gonna see this whole thing
differently but you're trying to take
care of her and her have all of her
little girl feelings sorry you're like a
grown woman now
and grown women own up to grown men on
up to
when we do something stupid i've done
plenty of stupid i made a reputation
with it
i made a living off of the fact that
i've done stupid
and tell people all the time i'm not
there's nothing no shame in that the
shame is staying in it